[Music]
well
last episode we started out with a
rendition
of the beatles does anyone want to sing
a ramstein they're all
living in america america
it's fundamental or david bowie
i'm afraid of americans you know what
just because i say it eric doesn't
actually mean you have to do it
i know i know i'm scary and
authoritarian
plastic pills is my bastard
i feel like we're trying to subvert uh
anthems here so i don't know
all right you listener hey you're
listening to
the pill pod the foremost anti-20 year
old podcast on the internet
just say yo if you're 20 you're dumb as
[ __ ] and you don't know it yet
you've probably read one book and you
believe whatever that book said
and i know that as a former 20 year old
actually
you probably didn't even read it yet you
just read tweets and youtube summaries
of it so we're here to tell you
this podcast is about cutting you down i
think when i was 12 i think when i was
20 i was really into
richard dawkins the god delusion oh that
sounds
great you're a country i can see that
yeah so that that should tell you
everything
yeah my favorite book at 20 was closing
of the american mind by ellen bloom
which i read as holy scripture rather
than
reactionary conservative right-wing
hegelianism well at least i was like uh
that
that book has some like intellect behind
it compared to richard dawkins at least
yeah it's well written too it's
extremely well written but the
the prem or the theses that he develops
are not
are they don't represent my views today
it's sloppy it's a sloppy book and it's
grandiose it's very much an old man
saying get off my lawn
speaking of american minds today the
great gatsby
american minds
[Laughter]
hey if your favorite book at 20 was
great gatsby
no one's going to complain about that
that's not bad
it's a safe choice today
we are talking about america
we are not in america geographically but
america
is certainly in us and it's the center
of our world
culturally speaking we're in the
americas plural
[Music]
uh with us is noam chomsky's grandson
eric
how are you doing eric hey elizabeth
warren's nephew
victor politics guy okay
and this is going to confuse you because
today we actually have two
victors we're going to call the other
one uh we'll call him iron curtain baby
victor
sounds about right yeah unless you
unless you have a better idea we could
we could do the latino versus the
romanian victor or we could do
tenor versus base victor to be fair
most of my relatives from the iron
curtain are now in america so you can
just call me american victor maybe
that'll be simpler for today's topic
yeah
kentucky i was wondering today about the
etymology of the word kentucky do you
know what it is
no i don't no i didn't look it up i
i was really hoping oh oh i thought you
were i thought you were going to go
we'll have to crowdsource that one but
um yeah i just know like um
the capital louisville is lowville and
people look at you very confusedly if
you say
louisville it's also not the capital
louisville would be a french origin
right
yeah so just make sure you say lowville
and they won't look at you funny
and for all those angry kentuckians out
there listening to us the capital is
actually frankfurt
uh kentucky not louisville well i mean
the biggest city so clearly
full disclosure we are all canadians
here so yeah so they have a german
a german capital their largest city is a
french
plant yeah and we don't know the
etymology of the word kentucky
anyway okay but yeah
talking about america on a critical
theory philosophy podcast
uh we of course are going to trend
towards
the mythos perhaps of re of america
uh what we might call american civic
religion
uh manifest destiny city on a hill the
puritan founding revolution all that
but just like you don't ask a fish about
water we don't ask americans
about america you ask us um and there's
a long tradition of european
intellectuals [ __ ] on america
for being you know myopic or
uh naively optimistic from tocqueville
or de tocqueville
to adorno to beaudrillard um and now we
have our very own
european critic here with us we've
already mentioned
him victor uh victor what is your
intellectual background or
your research areas that are different
from ours
yeah so i'd say my wheelhouse is mostly
in literature and history
actually started with american
literature which is why we're discussing
that today
but i gravitated more towards the
renaissance so now i'm looking
specifically at um
england's contact with the mediterranean
during the renaissance but
for all intents and purposes today i'm
an americanist so
the rest of us are all blank studies and
blank
theory but we have a real true to the
true blood literature person it probably
makes sense to call him
to call him literature victor and me
politics victor all right
we got literally
[Laughter]
we won't joke too much about things
being lit but go on
paul we are not 20 after all yeah right
in fact we're decidedly yes anti-20 year
old here specifically yeah
we're anti-heba file and antsy 20 year
old yeah
and an anti-turn-based anti-turn base
too
that one has not been aired yet so don't
spoil like my cold open for the next oh
whoops
um okay so victor i test i mean
litvik i tasked you with coming up with
uh our initial talking points so
if we go back to america what are the
important events
what is defined american identity and
where do we get the mythos
from absolutely yeah i mean
there's always kind of been this tension
in the american story
and i think what's interesting is that
we're seeing an inflection point from
that today in some of these protests a
lot of this can kind of be seen as
maybe a renegotiation of aspects of
america's civil religion
and when we talk about civil religion i
mean all nations have rituals and myths
that kind of form a sense of citizenship
and identity right
but i think america is really unique
maybe among western nations in
particular since
some of these narratives kind of
arguably transcend nationalism and they
almost start to share more structural
similarities with organized religion
so when you think about things like um
sacred texts you have the declaration of
independence the constitution
you think about prophetic figures you've
got the founding fathers you have sacred
space
with battlefields uh monuments in
washington dc and so on
and of course you have rituals and
commemorations which keep this stuff
fresh and which kind of renew this
narrative for every generation so the
pledge of allegiance to the flag
not kneeling during the national anthem
these are the kinds of things that kind
of
bind americans cohesively together in a
way which has really kind of
made america a very successful brand
right
fundamentally like it's projected its
soft power beyond its domestic borders
for many decades now
and to some extent you could say this is
deserved i mean america did fight the
first successful war of independence
it is the world's oldest modern
democracy
but what's interesting is that what
we're seeing today is a lot of the
younger generations are kind of pushing
back on a lot of this
these myths about american
exceptionalism
and no longer kind of taking it as
gospel
that america is the sort of shining city
on the hill so
in terms of mapping out the tension a
little bit more historically i think
it's useful to just kind of have this
reference point in mind that
the traditional story as you mentioned
pills is the
pilgrims landing at plymouth rock around
1620
and this idea of america as
originating with religious refugees
right it was this nation founded on the
ideals of religious freedom and
rebellion from unjust government
but what people sometimes overlook is
that the actual earliest english
settlement
in north america was jamestown in 1607
and that was a trading colony that
points to the
alternate history of america which is
this country founded on
commercial interests mercantile profits
and relevant to the legacy today
the the human trafficking of millions of
slaves
so those kinds of two central reference
points plymouth
and jamestown kind of purity or profit
that's kind of what's been uh at the
heart of the tension
you could argue in the american
narrative which
is now clearly being kind of
renegotiated in the protest movements
in some of the pushback and the issues
surrounding confederate monuments and
stuff like that but
that's an interesting kind of way to
start thinking about where america's
civil religion comes from
and why it's still very much sort of uh
hot an issue today
yeah well that was a beautiful intro so
thanks for that
if anyone unless anyone objects why
don't we deal with each of those
separately we can talk about the
commercial
the commercial story um and then the
religious
story and obviously there's a lot of
overlap especially in terms of
the sacred words like freedom religious
freedom and economic freedom go together
but do you want to deal with those
independently guys well i was
well i was kind of hoping to just
comment on what was just said um
just from a political perspective i
think that very well put analysis
makes me think about like today it's
like another way from like in terms of
what kind of
like political rhetoric and you know the
culture war happening in the states i
think like that
those two founding stories are
interesting because they make me think
about
the struggle of between the two sides of
the culture
where one side wants to emphasize the
plymouth rock story
and wants to say you know that america
is exceptional and is this sort of like
positive
view of america and then there's i think
the
who would maybe be more associated with
black lives matter and like
more of the what people would
pejoratively call like social justice
wars which they're they only want the
narrative to be right like
the slavery narrative and like they
don't ever want to hear anybody say for
example
oh well america was also like a good
idea they want to like in some ways
reduce it to
oh like actually america is like an
inherently racist country which of
course
it is in in a way but it's like you know
not the only story there's like
uh and i think it's just interesting
that in the political side you do see
that struggle between
in some ways like the worst examples are
people who just want to reduce
america to just like one of those things
and don't want to
don't want to emphasize like the more
complicated story
if i if i could put it that way one
thing that differentiates
uh because we're in canada as most of
our repeat listeners certainly know
there's this the sense of the city on a
hill narrative
this uh religious freedom and then
tied into that america is the best of
course it's the best what could be
better than this
um i'm finding that is more and more
a boomer default position it doesn't
seem like young people interpret
american nationalism
and you know flag kneeling um in the
same way
that that older boomer generation would
right yeah i think also uh
i guess the thing that i find
interesting about
about the the tension in the in this in
the two sides of the american stories in
some ways like
the like maybe a more optimistic read of
america would be like the fact that we
have people kneeling to
to draw attention to those things like
it's there's something very
american about that like even in the
ideas of the founding fathers like the
like taking like taking on your freedom
you're absolutely right victor because i
was just gonna add that uh yeah
protest is definitely kind of like
ingrained in the dna of america and
that's what's very interesting is like
there are so many reference points to
kind of draw from it's such a
complicated history of
competing narratives that it's very hard
to kind of ultimately rule out anything
as being un-american in that context and
so
that's why this stuff that's constantly
being renegotiated in terms of
narratives and counter narratives
because
nobody really has the last word on this
stuff there's so many communities
throughout american history that each
have their own kind of alternate history
right yeah in some ways the whole
working out of that those two narratives
is like very american in a certain sense
maybe absolutely yeah
so we have uh at least three events
that i think we should talk about i mean
none of us are real
historians except for for maybe
no okay he's shaking his head none of us
are real historians
we're all canadians let's let's leave it
at that yeah
yeah we didn't learn this in school
we've got these three main events though
we got plymouth rock
puritans landing here uh frontierism
comes out of there
then we have i guess the the civic
founding which is
uh you know jefferson washington madison
writing the right in the sacred text the
holy text for
the nation and then we have the civil
war which brings in that conflict over
uh freedom what does freedom mean and
then the issue of slavery obviously
being the main the main visible issue
in terms of that uh do we want to just
do them in order do you think
yeah sure that sounds great because they
all kind of bleed into these issues that
we're seeing today
so yeah the the city on the hill is
something that kind of gets banned
around a lot and of course it's been
recycled over and over again in like
republican speeches and stuff
but yeah it comes from john winthrop's
speech
in around 1630 i believe which is uh
he was kind of delivering a sermon to
the puritans it was way before like the
country had actually been funded but
he was reminding them that because they
were one of the first permanent
settlements
in north america that the rest of the
world would look to them as an example
right so he's quoting from the bible
he's calling this settlement a city on a
hill
because they have to show the rest of
the world that they are going to be
doing something different here than the
old world that they left behind
so this is where you get the idea of
like america being this elect nation
chosen by god to sort of like lead the
world forward into the modern age but
it starts a very humble origins yeah and
also the boomer
notion why don't we just we'll just
shorthand it all was boomer notion but
the boomer notion
you know this is a christian nation this
is not a muslim nation
um that's doesn't come with the event of
the founding that comes from this
puritan
fleeing religious persecution uh
into the darkness you have like chosen
people this is the new the new
israelites
fleeing egypt and founding this new
country uh on christian
or puritanical christian ideas
which is what's so ironic too though
because like the whole idea is that they
were religious refugees fighting for
religious liberty like right away you
have like different sects
kind of being established so even before
like the us itself as a country
there there are it's not like it's one
unified religion even then yeah
well yeah i think that's interesting
like i think it speaks to the point the
thing i was kind of talking about before
that like
anytime you dig a little bit deeper like
people will try to define
like the myth of america in a specific
way whether it's a positive myth or a
negative myth
and it seems like the struggle right now
is to it's like whose
reductive story is gonna win but like
ultimately if you just like
dig a little bit you'll see that it's
much more complicated than
the reductive story that people like to
give whether it's a very negative story
or a positive story
well that's the thing about myth right
it doesn't need to be
factual it can be something less or
something more
than factual but that's what's in the
background here
because we were talking about one of the
most important kinds
of myths aren't we uh the origin myth or
the founding myth
yeah and what parallels would you point
to uh when you're talking
in those terms eric i mean what's in the
background here
is i guess as canadians and outsiders
were digging into the collective
unconscious of america so i was going to
say
you're giving boomers way too much
credit because they're they're not
their world view isn't consciously based
on all of this
nuance and historical awareness these
sorts of stories
have sank into the collective
unconscious and they're passed down
through generations
you know one of the things growing up in
canada i always noticed about the states
was that
that patriotism that we don't so much
have in canada is that they're
so proud to be american they're this
melting pot right but we're
called the cultural mosaic we don't melt
everybody's myths into one sort of
collective myth we
keep them apart a little bit that
that cultural mosaic thing is totally
our mythology though like we're
indoctrinated that in like fifth grade
grade five total yeah it's hammered in
america's bad
they're a melting pot they don't let
people keep their identities we let them
keep them
we're like yeah we're like one of those
things that
babies have above their cribs when they
are when they're growing up and learning
to articulate and they're they're
hitting at that
that spinny mobile above their bed
that's what i always
associated with canada if i could sum it
up in an image
that's our myth yeah i mean not to make
this about canada
but yeah like i feel in some ways we
have the benefit of like watching
seeing that we're right next to america
we have the benefit of watching them put
egg on their face and then we can just
define ourselves as being not that
exactly yeah yeah we have listeners in
the uk
and australia and they probably have
their own
inverse relationship with uh the united
states culturally but ours is definitely
we're we're like them but we're better
and we're like them but we're not as
mean
and we never had slavery so we're we're
a better colonial we had slavery we had
slavery but
it wasn't to the extent on an extremely
small scale
relatively it wasn't um but we have our
own difficult racial issues as well
obviously historically with the
indigenous and yeah
yeah are of course our own genocidal we
have it
we're certainly not free of genocide
that's for sure as justin trudeau was
quick to remind everyone when he was
asked about uh
trump's response to the riots he
deflected to
canada's own you know backyard yeah
yeah well he was the one kicking kicking
them off the land so that they could put
a pipeline through like a few months ago
which feels like
10 years ago yeah anyway sorry a little
bit off track so if we can get back to
this chosen people thing
you know we are going into face the
darkness
with only god on our side a darkness
meaning
uh you know the land the land had to be
tamed uh they had to deal with
the natural people the savages of course
again i'm talking in mythic terms but
it was them against the entire world
because god had chosen them to establish
a new way of living on earth a godly way
of living on earth
and maybe we can come back to that but
unless anyone has any objections then we
have the
the founding the moment of the founding
when colonies are established
and then we have the separation of
church and state as
the guiding you know enlightenment type
of principle that says we are
not a christian nation which is kind of
the opposite of what had been set up
until that point
well i'm also i was just thinking about
the
the aspect of the founding that is also
mythological
because it it actually reminds me of
something i think i was like second year
like some north american politics class
i took and
i still remember this professor like he
had such a weird way of lecturing he
would like yell at you and i remember
him yelling at us that
uh he's like they weren't interested in
like being amer like american they just
wanted to be like
englishmen like they just wanted their
rights as englishmen like you know and
it's like so
that's another aspect of the mythology
right that they weren't actually like
there's no grand plan of building this
patriotic that only came after
they were denied uh right like their
their rights that what they saw is
obviously the unfair
like taxation without representation and
all that stuff and
the t i don't i'm not actually that
great in that story but yeah maybe maybe
you can speak to that
you're i think your angry prof was right
yeah because initially like
i don't think the idea was to have a
democracy they kind of even wanted
george washington to become their king
at some point but
the idea was more like jefferson's ideal
at least was of an agrarian nation of
like rich farmers
who didn't have to pay tax to england
that was basically the whole point
yeah and then it became this broader
kind of social experiment
and we kind of get the myths that we
have today but you're right actually
yeah
i mean maybe if they would have just
like left them alone a little bit the
english america would have been just
like a bigger canada or something they
would have like had a slow evolution
like in a slow withdrawal from the crown
i don't know maybe
can you guys tell me then um because i i
i know
nothing about this at all so i can serve
as the ignorant
uh questioner in this respect why then
if they were if this was their main goal
why is their constitution
so obsessed almost with the distribution
of powers and equal branches of
government
it's like you mentioned to um in many
ways the the founding fathers at least
were kind of children of the
enlightenment a lot of them were deists
so they kind of believed in a supreme
power but less so in some of the aspects
of organized religion
and so when they kind of had this chance
to start from scratch they did kind of
produce this kind of enlightenment
document almost yeah which
does seem quite progressive for its time
but you'll you'll notice still that like
a lot of the fine print still only only
talks about men owning property
it's still at the same time kind of a
product of its time so
and obviously it is interesting though
yeah and obviously there's a lot of
debates among the founders right that's
what the federalist papers are right
they're just like constantly debating
back and forth like how to set up
the constitution they are really worried
about uh i mean i'm not good with who
was arguing for what but i know that
some of them were very very
concerned about power and like they just
wanted to avoid like another king like i
think their their goal maybe
you could correct me if i'm wrong on
this but i like the way i understand is
their goal was to avoid
having another situation which they just
fought against the british for right
like they didn't want like
concentration of power where somebody
would start unjustly taxing everybody so
they had all they had in the federalist
papers right they're debating like how
can we avoid that like that's
like how do can we avoid concentration
of power i think federalist 10 might be
the one but if i'm not mistaken but
anyway
that's a that's a good point because
reading the federalist papers you can
almost see them
going through the history of england and
saying okay and then this happened how
do we prevent that from happening and
then including
you know separation of power so yeah to
your point pills i think a lot of it was
kind of born out of self-interest as
well like they wanted to make sure that
they would secure
the freedoms that they had just gained
and that's why they're so meticulous in
kind of
highlighting and outlining the freedoms
in that sense yeah right because this is
really the first
bourgeoisie state bourgeoisie founded
bourgeoisie writing the rules we're not
uh progressively uh overthrowing an
aristocracy
yeah another way to say that might be uh
america
is an experiment in the separation of
church and state
and as as diverse as america's culture
as its political structures are
and and thinking about politics are
largely inherited from
britain such as the division of judicial
executive and legislative powers
that comes from the sort of british
tradition of political thinking
yeah so there's there's a kind of a
weird and
and the and the separation of church and
state thing is quite ironic for
how how religious they are these days
and how much it's still an issue
well i think in some ways it kind of
backfired uh in a weird way like their
obsession with
separation of powers like and like the
thing that distinguishes them obviously
from a british parliamentary system is
like
i think they were probably worried that
the british parliamentary system where
the prime minister
is in the house and not separated from
the house
was that like that could cut that
concentrates too much power
in in the legislative and i think that
like it ended up kind of biting them in
the ass because now we're seeing that
nothing gets done
and like literally you can't get
consensus on anything and i think like
from from my perspective from a
political perspective like i think
parliamentary systems
are stronger because you have more
swings in power you have someone win a
majority government then they just get
all the power
they get to do what they want and we
actually get to see what works and what
doesn't and then next time around you
can vote them out
and then the next person actually gets
an opportunity to do what they said they
would do
now with all the separation of powers
they literally know
and get no opportunity to actually like
legislate what they promised
because like nobody can agree and then
everybody blames everybody else for not
getting anything done but the system
doesn't allow them to get anything done
anyway that's my like
political institutional rant which maybe
doesn't no but you're right yeah
whatever
well it makes sense go ahead yeah it
makes sense
i think that not a lot happens right in
in that sort of
political system because as soon as you
become
unmoored from religion as a sort of
moral guide to how you do your politics
you need a kind of cultural conservatism
to step in
as a guide for what happens
it's a lot like the way that english
changed so much
whereas french and the romance languages
like that stay the same because they're
so close to latin latin was like their
grammatical moral system that kept them
the same but
to your point also eric about like how
ironic it is that the states are so
religious today i
i think that's directly a result of the
separation of powers because
you see in countries like france or
england which did have like a strong
kind of national religion
they actually became secular faster
whereas
in countries which didn't have a strong
religion
like america and even turkey for example
they are still
quite religious themselves like the
among the peoples so
when something is sort of mandated by
the government people tend to lose
interest
basically that's a good idea when
they're free to practice religion
then like you know it's much more
resilient that i mean
and i think that happened in canada too
right like we still technically have the
the crown
as like a religious placeholder and of
course we're more secular i think than
america
yeah and the anglican church
historically was more powerful in like
ontario for example exactly yeah
um i was reading today i dusted it off
alexis de tocqueville's democracy in
america and
what you were mentioning there in terms
of this separation
not being able to accomplish things was
his i think he called it the tyranny of
the majority
about a third of the way into the book
um and this was his critique of
the american system is that there's
they're too hopelessly
naive that uh they think if they make a
rule for everything
then they're going to have a spirit like
an esprit de cora or something like that
whereas he was comparing it to he's a
french aristocrat of course
so he and he's comparing it to uh france
and in france
he's saying like we have we have a unity
that they could never understand
basically because they're so what's the
word they're boxed in so much by their
common sense and self-interest
that they can't they don't have any
imagination basically is what he says
about them
um a repeated
european critique of america is that
they are
too pragmatic and have no imagination
right although uh
yeah i would elaborate on on the point
about separation of powers though i
think like
if if tocqueville would probably like
look now and be like okay that worry i
had about
too many too much ability to get things
done and a tyranny of the majority
like that's not happening in some ways
right like the thing i was pointing to
was that
the wit like the institutions don't
actually allow
anybody to to get anything done that
they want like
the majority almost has like no power to
get anything done anymore
what do you mean by that i think like i
see the united i see the states as
having basically two versions of one
party
well then the problem the problem is
like even when so like
when someone elects a president right
like they're they they run on all these
things
but then they also have to like in order
for the party who wins president to
actually get anything done
they would have to win presidency the
senate and the house of representatives
if even one of those things goes to the
other party then automatically you can't
get anything done
but the parties are the same and neither
of them want actually to do anything
right but they keep like but especially
lately they keep blocking everything
that the other party
tries to do and then like nobody gets
anything done because like uh
they're just using the institutions to
uh
to like prevent the other party from
getting from getting credit for getting
anything done so like
like i think the problem is that you're
a politics guy and i'm not
but yeah don't you think the system's
working according to what the founding
fathers wanted in preserving like
bourgeois landon or business
well i think what happened what's
changed in the last
30 years or so especially since like
newt gingrich in the 90s won
the so like for a long time in the 20th
century 40 years
the democrats pretty much always won the
house of representatives
and then like no matter even if the
president was republican but there was a
long tradition where they would actually
like come together
and have bipartisan support for bills
and usually it would be like
compromises over tax cuts or like some
little small incremental changes or
crime bills and they would come to an
agreement
but then but still like the power was
still divided so like maybe the
republicans would have the senate and
the democrats would have the house
but now what's happened after like newt
gingrich
basically won the house of
representatives for the republicans for
the first time in 40 years
um the politics became very toxic
and nobody and like newt gingrich was
like we have to stop working with our
democratic
allies that's making us look weak and he
basically like set the stage for
this like dysfunctional like we're not
going to work with you that you're
like why are you working with the enemy
so like now like the whole culture of
getting things done changed and that's
been dead pretty much now for like the
past
20 25 years because no one's willing to
work together anymore
yeah yeah the the gingrich revolution as
it's called maybe
like kind of led to the gridlock and
hyperpartisanship that you're talking
about victor absolutely absolutely
yeah and it's worth noting too that like
bill clinton himself was quite a
centrist actually like you kind of had
like the third way
yeah so even they were willing to kind
of like block even clinton's
bills and his efforts so that says a lot
about kind of how
partisan the politics had become by that
point yeah exactly yeah before that they
weren't like necessarily as partisan
there was a lot of working together
a lot of friendliness too across the
party and newt gingrich was just like
why are you like he literally
was quoted once it's like why are you
like going for drinks with your enemies
like what like stop it
like stop that's how you know joe biden
is a boomer he still
compliments like mike pence and stuff
yeah my good friend
my good friend across the aisle because
he's from that time
a relic of a time long gone yeah exactly
that's yeah exactly
all right this is a fine aside for
setting context but can we
uh move a little bit back into the
mythological
aspect of this no i it's fine i just
mean
like let's try to stay on the one topic
to deal with
how do you see either the christianity
narrative that we have
or the bourgeois self-interest narrative
um how is
america acting that out currently
well normally when we talk about uh like
history from a cultural hit a cultural
perspective so cultural history
we often talk about what myths or these
universal principles what they tend to
exclude
and i think for example the protests
sort of demonstrate the exclusion of the
sort of alternative history about
slavery and you know the conquest of the
americas
and the way that that story is sort of
told to
americans as they grow up and they're
sort of indoctrinated into this
into this not only like understanding of
their own history but into this sort of
mythology through which they understand
sort of the whole world as well in their
like everyday life
and in a sense we can't separate the
way that we interpret freedom or the way
we interpret americans
talking about freedom and that we can't
separate that specifically from
the cold war and communism because that
is what the source
of the rhetoric that we have in terms of
that we are free they are not we are
enlightened they are not we are
christian they are not
that kind of exacerbates all these
initial tendencies that we can find
uh from before in the founding and in
plymouth rock
and to your question pills about kind of
how this is still reverberated even
today i mean like weber talks about this
beautifully in the protestant ethic and
the spirit of capitalism
where he argues that basically
protestant morality kind of became
secularized right
yeah and that's why even today we kind
of follow the almighty dollar in the u.s
and free markets are kind of sacrosanct
that's still sort of the legacy of this
idea of protestant hard work kind of
granting you and guaranteeing you a
place in the afterlife basically
which became secularized and led to the
sort of hyper capitalist you know
neoliberal state that the u.s still is
today
this is a perfect way to transition over
from that religious
story to the the story of money the
story of capital
um and capital that is released from the
aristocracy
because uh a lot of like the new york
area for example was founded by
the dutch and the dutch had were this
reformist
calvinist tradition that weber's talking
about they had no interest in culture
and civic religion
basically they were going everywhere in
the world that they were going
uh you know indonesia south africa just
to
extract resources and take them back
home
and then you get this sort of bald um
cold-eyed let's make some money here and
get that get
gtfo yeah so so probably to
understand america's position in
sort of the world right now and the and
the colonial history of america
we have to understand that sort of myth
of um
of uh manifest destiny and now today
it's kind of gone global
and cultural uh and also the american
dream
that that what you were saying the
releasing of money from uh
from the aristocracy and now it's all
sort of up for grabs and the protestant
work ethic can give you this
if you work hard you'll have upward
mobility in in america right in my
my favorite book when i was 20 the great
gatsby is
is all about the the american dream and
you could point to that as
one of the myths that developed probably
pretty close to the way america was
founded on this sort of
idea of the american dream and empty
space
wilderness land come work the land join
your labor to it and it'll become your
property
right anybody anybody can make it yeah
emptiness
emptiness empty space in quotes of
course because yeah
the entire place is populated and that
goes back to my point what is left out
of these myths right all of the native
american history
is left out slavery is left out
colonialism and
domination is all left out right i mean
i was
oh go on i was gonna say i wonder if
like i guess we kind of said this before
but like
myth is maybe like by definition its
function is that it leaves things out
like like like you couldn't have a myth
that is like a nuanced picture of
reality
i think so because it's not a it's it's
a i mean i'm
a semiotics guy okay so it's a semiotic
resource right and it's not neutral
that's right it's not it's not neutral
it has a
it has a bias it has a bent and when we
buy into it
it affects the way we think about things
because it affects the way we sort of
express ourselves
the way we understand our social reality
here's a here's like a controversial
here's a controversial question which
maybe
maybe you'll want to cut out i don't
know but like like do you think that
there's
like is the myth is it also the case
that like like there's a counter myth
happening right now
that like wants to reduce america to
just like racist
or is that anonymous or is it
is it functioning is it functioning and
to some extent maybe that's too
controversial well here this is a good
question because i was thinking today
like
when i heard you kind of hear this stuff
when you're younger and you go
um when you're 20 when you're a dumbass
you hear like america is a racist state
and you
you hear that as a 20 year old go okay
yeah like
this this person has an agenda sure
racist things happen but it's not a
racist state
but america is a racist state
it is like the laws the very first laws
that they wrote down
were to protect the ownership of people
as chattel
um and that that is like in the in
document day one
even though it says you know uh
self-evident all men are created equal
but
men we're landowning males only but
white white males yeah but isn't it also
the case that like built into those
documents was the ingredients to
push back against racism to like right
it's like isn't it also the case that
there's like a path dependency to the to
the way that the constitution and all
these things were written
yeah that basically built the groundwork
to like uh to undermine racism yeah
that's the paradox because you have
martin luther king of course quoting
all men are created equal exactly so
like it's just that's what i mean by
that's what i mean by like like you know
you can't reduce
uh america to like one of these two
things uh right either like uh like you
know a shining city on a hill or like a
racist
of course it is racist i mean that's
undeniable and just for the reasons you
said
but reducing it right like you know it's
also
an idea that allows for
negotiation and uh changes and
and you know like uh over injustice as
well
and that's the great debate today as
well over like what do we do about
george washington and thomas jefferson
right because as we know they were slave
owners they had this as well but
is it true that perhaps they were
looking towards future generations when
this would no longer be the case
we kind of view their more complicated
legacy yeah this is still very much
being negotiated
right i don't know i don't know if i
want to keep that and i feel like i
could get cancelled for like asking that
question
i don't know but it's an important
question though victor because like yeah
this idea of like how deep does the
racism go
and these questions now about maybe even
removing washington statue and like
jefferson himself like he had like
children with his slaves like it's it's
crazy because
when you do like dna tests of
jefferson's descendants today and
there's like family reunions
it's very awkward because some of them
are white
and some of them are not so white and
it's like they're clearly all descended
from jefferson
yeah so like even in like the literal
dna of
the country this stuff is so messy and
so mixed yeah
yeah i can trace my family back to the
mayflower
really no no
[Laughter]
the canadian mayflower
victor i don't actually want to take
that question out because i don't think
it's a wrong
question to ask um okay but then
i guess the question is how do you
define
a racist belief in a racist
age and were they were they writing
these laws
specifically and we could move into the
civil war um in those sorts of
discussions but
were they were these laws that were
that appear to be written
to defend commercial interest and
commercial interest in this case
means the ownership of people with skin
that's darker than
white um can you base a society on that
did they do that
can you just call it commercial interest
and say they weren't trying to be racist
and try to excuse them
no in that way yeah um so those are
questions i don't know the answer to
them
no those are good you can't bring
morality into history
transplant it as a on a one-to-one ratio
as if these things are the same things
that they were talking about in the way
that we're talking about them
no of course and i think uh yeah i mean
that's i mean that example
i mean that's just like obviously led to
incredibly racist outcomes
but i was also more just thinking about
how like you know the american story is
both the story of
colonialism and destruction of
indigenous people and
like slavery and it's also a country of
you know uh
all amendments and uh freedom of
freedoms and like the the tools to fight
against those things eventually right
and it's the country of martin luther
king just as much as it's the country of
david duke i was reading like i said
tocqueville uh says there's three races
in america and he has a whole chapter on
the history or the future of the three
races the indian the negro and the
anglo-american
um and he was pretty horrified by
the treatment of the the blacks and the
indi and the indians or negroes and
indians as he called them
but he he was horrified by this and he
wrote it in
like 1850 or so
and he said like these he basically said
what i'm saying this system is designed
to have these people in the position
that they're in and they're so miserable
that they don't know how miserable they
are because their
entire history has been completely
erased they don't hear the language of
their fathers they only hear the
language of the master
um they don't have
the african gods they only have this one
god that they have to serve
um and it's the god of the master and it
was shocking actually to me to be
reading this
written by an aristocratic french guy
in 1850 saying exactly the same thing
that is being said outside
now right or said by malcolm x or said
by any of these revolutionary
leaders that are like you said using the
language of
the founding fathers against the
institutions created by the founding
fathers
i was just going to say in some ways
like i think america it has built in
like another way of putting it to use
like a
critical theory term right in some sense
like america has ingredients built into
it to do an eminent critique
right like it's built right into it to
just like critique it on its own
standards
the other context too i think for when
de tocqueville was writing is that by
that point it was largely the south the
more agrarian
states which were dependent on slaves
and the north had largely freed most of
its
african-american population but yeah so
that's where you kind of get the
divide in terms of commercial interest
which basically leads to the civil war
because
as we might know like the north was much
more industrial and they kind of
phased out of that sort of uh economy
much earlier than the south
oh i was just going to express
skepticism whenever whenever you
encounter that kind of magnanimous
uh concern uh in these earlier writers
i'm always kind of skeptical of their
motivations
not because i think they're straight up
racist but i
i do kind of make a distinction between
racism and racialism
whereas racism is more um pointed
and based on an assumption of
inferiority and is sort of active
racialism is a lot more just like
eurocentrism
right this is what anybody has to
struggle with in
academia when we're reading old authors
especially if you're
female or if you're not white you just
have to struggle with the canon and
you get you struggle with this idea that
they just assumed
other people were inferior to white
christians and that women were kind of
second-class citizen
and even if they expressed that
magnanimity i brought up this guy uh
bartelo mudella casas who was a big
critic of um
of colonialism when it was just starting
up what what
columbus had started to establish in the
americas was
was shocking to him but as a christian i
mean
did he have any black friends what were
his opinion on women that would be an
entirely different matter
for him he could separate his christian
concern for human beings
from his sort of eurocentric racialism
yeah a lot of this stuff is kind of
tricky to contextualize sometimes
especially because like i think even for
de tocqueville
the french revolution was partly
inspired by the american revolution so
like i'm not sure
how what sort of a dance he might be
playing even in terms of like
the compliments and the criticism that
he's kind of giving the us but yeah
it's always worth kind of questioning
the author's own motives absolutely
it's bringing up the uh the civil war i
think one of the
like most puzzling and maybe in some
ways
i find like uh like i guess from
like a non-american perspective to me
like the the revisionist history that
that
still was happening up to now from like
southerners
about the civil war is like a is like a
fascinating phenomenon to see the way
that they try to
it's almost like it's it almost is
reminiscent of like holocaust denial in
the in the sense that it's like or at
least
it's like a soft form of holocaust
denial in the sense of like being
well it wasn't really about racism it
was about like states rights or like i
don't know it's like
this weird you're absolutely right yeah
and that's basically like a slice of
american mythology which isn't often
kind of like understood outside of the
states because
this stuff was like literally kind of
being taught in textbooks in the south
yeah but it's basically the idea of like
the lost cause right that like oh
the south wasn't really fighting to
preserve slavery it was about states
rights it was about these like
valiant aristocratic knights in a
pastoral society fighting the war of
northern aggression it's like
you're right it's a it's a form of
holocaust denial because like
unlike germany which kind of underwent
like denotification after world war ii
the south never really kind of came to
terms with its own history
in terms of being kind of like a society
founded on white supremacy
and that's where you kind of get this
weird fixation on like confederate
monuments and everything is
it's it's kind of like the sons and
daughters of the confederacy not really
being able to accept that
what what their parents actually fought
for and kind of you know
revising a lot of this history and um
basically in part it's sort of a dog
whistle to white supremacy
but in many ways it's also just kind of
trying to redeem like their heritage
in a very clumsy way yeah yeah totally
and like you know the myth of the
southern gentleman and there's like all
this like yeah like you said i like the
way you put it the
these like nights in like a pastoral
setting or whatever what do you call
them like aristocratic knights of the
south like
it's it's crazy because even something
as like horrific as like ku klux klan
kind of comes from that like it's
originally this idea of like
brave vigilantes kind of like protecting
their neighborhoods from like the
the northern hordes and you know
african-american gangs like it's
it's so warped but these people actually
believe that to some extent like
it's myths which really took on a very
dangerous life of their own
it's fascinating the the extent of the
revisionist history that happened like
there's
there's really interesting like effort
like you said to like change the
textbooks to make it more uh
palatable and you know all like you can
to say it bluntly like i guess from a
canadian perspective
or whatever it's just like i look at
that history and i'm like you're trying
to celebrate
like traitors and uh like like slave
owners
this is almost two traders it's almost
too easy
of a an example of ideology
in the sense that this the civil war was
an economic
conflict it was not a moral conflict
probably at
all like the northern industrialists
probably did not give a [ __ ]
about slaves and i think that's true
south carolina i think used to be the
richest state
in the union but then new york and uh
i guess illinois new england started
ramping up
in terms of uh factory labor and things
like that
so i i guess the moral issue with
slavery
probably comes into there um yeah in a
sense and but in in another sense the
civil war never ended it's a war of city
against country
yeah and the country lost but the
country doesn't want to admit that they
lost so then you get this
reimagining of all those things that you
just mentioned then we get the symbols
we have the
kkk we have the monuments that are
every every time a monument is put up
it's because like a black mayor was just
elected or something like that
or taken taken down you mean right no
put up oh like they're put up and
they're put up even in the 90s but then
you have right i
i saw this on a youtube video or
something but it's a graph
of when all the monuments were put up
and
it's like during the civil rights
movement then there's a huge
boom of statues yeah they're extremely
reactionary
in the most crude possible way it's like
now this
this is the history um but it's
completely a veneer over this
actual material conflict over ownership
which is a uh kind of a bourgeoisie
conflict so you know all is
not well in the bourgeois the bourgeois
ideology state
well i think you bring up a really good
point about the fact that when the
statues were put up because
like what we're seeing now obviously
unprecedented and i think to be
celebrated
like huge changes like i think more
statues are getting taken down now than
there have been in a really long time
and uh
and you know a lot of people are like
well we can't forget our history but i
think that it's so important to remind
people well no these aren't like statues
that were put up
like right after the civil war like a
lot of them were literally
like middle fingers to black people
during the civil rights movement to
remind them to be like
oh like remember this history like yeah
like actually you know it wasn't some
old statue that's been up for like 100
plus years
do i don't i'm not very well versed in
world history but is there any
movement like this of traitors and
losers just being celebrated like this
like they didn't even they didn't even
do good in the war
yeah i mean it's kind of like naming a
new new york's airport like you know bin
laden
airport or something like it it doesn't
make sense when you look at it that way
of course
but like that's the thing like the
confederacy kind of won like the shadow
war in that sense
they kind of got reappropriated into
sort of the mainstream
and i think this kind of maybe this can
be explained back to this idea of like
american revolution being
ingrained as one of the founding myths
too it's like if you reinterpret this as
like
oh this was just like the second
american revolution they were fighting
for their rights this was about like
individualism
that's why these like symbols of like
white supremacy can kind of be
reappropriated into like
symbols of broader american mythology
like oh the confederate flag
representing this idea of like
anti-authority and individualism and
like it has broader signifiers than what
it actually
means that's why perhaps it's persisted
so long
right you're right they do they really
do co-opt like those original kind of
founding myths of like don't tread on me
but then like applied it to their kind
of like uh
civil or their civil war mythology they
co-opted that original mythology of like
america versus yeah and that's why it's
so hard to kind of like call somebody
out for racism in that case because it's
like
no my my ancestors didn't fight for to
protect slaves they were like fighting
for their land they were too poor to
afford slaves or like whatever
[ __ ] like you know you might hear
so it's it's really messy but it's very
encouraging to see that like even nascar
and
like corporations like that have kind of
found this to be like okay this is like
a toxic brand we can't be associated
with like the confederate flag or these
things anymore yeah
yes i actually saw that uh that even in
mississippi in the state
house it was bipartisan bill introduced
from both democrat and republican to
change the flag because if you guys
google the mississippi flag the
confederate battle flag is actually part
of the mississippi flag
so they're going to change it
potentially and you kind of think this
is how is this not done
until now yeah
why does it why does it take
yeah i don't know i mean yeah i mean as
a non-american as a non-american it is
hard to like
in my mind it's just like you know the
significance of like the swastika and
the significance of like a confederate
battle flag to me like i don't know like
as a non-american they just like
don't like what they were fighting for
like just doesn't seem that different to
me but obviously
i'm not an american and certainly have
you guys have you guys heard of the
movie uh
the birth of a nation i don't know yeah
why is it
why is this heralded so well because it
has good panning techniques or some [ __ ]
it's like the triumph of the will but
america version absolutely yeah that's a
big reason of like why you get this
flare up of like
neoconfederacy and stuff in like 1910s
because like
there's this like cinematically very
accomplished movie
the birth of a nation which which was
made around then and it's all about
romanticizing the south
the clan being like heroes defending
their wives from like the northerners
and all that
and there's this amazing scene there
which is like
the main character sees his sister or
something being like harassed on the
street
and he's like it's a silent movie so
he's kind of like thinking this in his
head
oh i wish there was some way that i
could protect the innocent womenfolk of
this town and he's like
he sees some kids playing with sheets as
ghosts and he's like
i got it i'll put a mask on i'll form a
group would be like vigilantes
and it's literally like batman realizing
he has to like
put on a mask to fight crime it's just
larping from day one
yeah no and then that's how you get like
these like batman wannabes kind of like
putting on white sheets and then like
you know spreading hate crimes so like
it that's actually that movie alone was
like responsible for so much of this
revival of like
the new york confederate stuff yeah this
is like the
the homer of the american south
i mean it goes back to my point about i
think
without a sort of institutionalized
religion
that without that religious
traditionalism that cultural
conservatism sets in and that's what
sort of
keeps things the same because it's
oriented towards tradition
and history and and honoring the past
and when movies like that become sort of
inexplicably popular even when they're
not
great movies or they're kind of content
is great they feed into this
conservative mythology i guess you could
say not political conservatism just
conservatism in the sense of like
traditionalism it's just like oh in a
movie like uh
the mel gibson jesus movie uh passion of
the
passion of the racist alcoholic became
so inexplicably popular
it's because it repeats this old sort of
myth that americans just
love well the revolutionary myth
the vigilante myth is consistent in all
of these
uh patterns and i think that's something
that's very difficult for
me to understand because it's not part
of the
culture here i would say and i don't
know any american southerner so i think
that's another reason that i'm having
such a
such a problem reconciling the two
if if you think about how it permeated
even like comic books and everything
like i think there's actually been like
evidence that like a batman's creator
was influenced by that scene
in depicting like the origins of like
comic book vigilantes and stuff like
that like
you think about the appeal that that
stuff still obviously has in like
popular culture and
it's not hard to see maybe how like back
in the 1910s this stuff clearly kind of
like spoke to this
humiliated region of the states which
was looking to kind of like redeem its
national heroes yeah
right it plays into the the
individualism perfectly though the the
vigilantesm is just like the photo
negative
of the individualist citizen law-abiding
person right it's just the photo
negative of that batman
is a is a good american citizen
if you put if you put ggx glasses on and
watch that movie
it actually looks a lot more like
something from the 50s
it's interesting but yeah my friend uh
it's too bad yeah my friend tucker who
was
living here uh doing his masters he's
like he's a southern american and he
actually like loves
uh civil war history and he like he's
not like sympathetic to be
but i always found it puzzling how he
has like a fascination
and like i could feel the temptation
almost in him to like
to like get caught up in the mythos even
though he like knew it was [ __ ] but
there's like
something ingrained i think when you
grow up as a southerner it's just so
it's like in the air
so much around you that mythology that's
like you spend your sunday afternoons
after you go to your
stupid baptist church then you go out
into a field and just larp for a day
grown men [ __ ] putting on uniforms
and pretending to shoot each other
is a reference activity you see alex
jones going along on the on the tank
yelling at people like people love
larping american
[ __ ] stereotypes like that and they
take it really seriously
by the way just going back to the
holocaust analogy too i think like
one thing that's easy for us to kind of
overlook is just how like devastating
this
war was for the south like we were
talking about the
economic impacts but like one of the
reasons why like their people are still
kind of talking about this it's like
uh so like before the war mississippi
for example was like one of the
wealthiest states
in the country and like after the war
even today it's like the 50th poorest
state
like the economic aftershocks are still
reverberating so like
part of the reason yeah these guys go
larping every sunday or whatever it's
like this stuff
still hits pretty close to home for them
like it's still like the deadliest
conflict in american history it's kind
of
in there and they're still they're still
suffering you're right you're right
they're like the most economically
hardest uh like like least successful
states
and uh it's interesting to the way like
a big part of i think the if we could
connect like sort of
the mythology that's at play right now
in kind of the partisan divide
is like i think that the southerners and
the more like obviously the
more rural voters right their mythology
there's almost as if
they're kind of the real americans like
and you hear this on fox news right like
you know middle america like they're the
they're the real americans and of course
and then they have all this
exceptionalism and how america is like
the strongest country and it's like the
most powerful country and economically
the most successful country but it's
kind of ironic that
uh that also like the people who are
saying that story the strongest are also
in the states that are like not
responsible like least responsible for
like america's success
so yeah right like america's economic
success is where all those like
un-american elitists live right all
those like coastal elites well here's
another signifier that we can throw in
uh right on what you're saying is
heartland like heartland
has this entire um
you know the the ex the limbs are not
real
new york california these are these are
parts that we could just cut off
and we'd still have the heart at least
yeah but it's just like
freaking collapsing coal mines in
virginia
and they think no we're the we're the
most real americans
um not these these [ __ ] libs who are
going to get college degrees they're
idiots
um and the jews that are taking over the
city but we are the real
heart of america when they're completely
expendable
members of a collapsing economy and
collapsing industry
i mean the only thing that allows
america to have their sweet military and
like all like and have all the money to
spend on those things is because of all
this economic success that the coasts
provide right like the industry and like
you know high-tech like everything
everything like
big and important when it comes to like
economics in america are in like you
know california
and uh like new york mostly well the
the military does use those little
virginia boys and throws them into
places to you know die test out test out
their raytheon body armor that they
right yeah and a lot of it is kind of
like false consciousness too where like
voters kind of
are told to vote against their interests
almost in these states from like fox
news and stuff like that where
you know on the one hand of course they
want the subsidies from the coastal
elites
on the other hand you know they kind of
reject their culture and everything but
yeah not not to just keep beating up on
the south yeah yeah
we're in a little bit of an echo chamber
here because they're just they're just
so consistently
dumb part part part of the reason why
yeah part of the reason why it is like
still a fascinating region is that like
it does actually have like a lot of
character it's got like probably the
best food in the states
like that's where like all american
music comes from so
there's a lot to redeem there it's just
kind of like when when you see things
flare up like they have in the last few
weeks over like
these dumb symbols from like the 1860s
that's where the question marks come
like what's going on here where like
this is still a thing yeah i should i
should also add of course that like
that delicious food and that great music
is probably also black america black
southern america
yes yeah
like it's important and important to to
emphasize that you mean like blue
bluegrass and stuff but even there yeah
i mean even there it's all come
maybe okay you can give them country
music but yeah
if the south and confederacy and
some of that stuff is all part of the
subtext of say
strongly part of the subtext of say the
republican party tent
but the democrats subtext is the cities
and urban life you can say things like
wall street
more of a more of a financial bent you
have the corporate democrats as well
and they're just as shitty as anybody
under the republican tent
the only the only people that i sort of
actively root for
that small little group of progressive
democrats
that supposedly don't exist because they
have to present
a unified front as a two-party system
right it's that negative partisanship i
have an interesting point i think that
can move us into that the final section
of this which is applying it to
current events um but like we're talking
about this blue grass turns into country
and you know uh black music becomes
appropriate it is rock and roll
and becomes rock and roll there's
another book by a european intellectual
named jean boudreau
on america and he talks about
new york specifically and how new york
is like the most cosmopolitan
culturally rich place on earth but it's
all because of people who are not white
white whites are just like the floating
signifier at the top that kind of make
money off it
off the whole rest of it but if we're
talking about white identity
the south are the only people that have
a white identity that is not sort of
this floating
um appropriating just blind mass
because they're saying no white is uh a
real thing
white is an identity white is a history
white
is this kind of stuff but then you have
the cosmopolitan
liberals who are like you know
apologizing taking responsibility
for it for all of racism um
and i wonder what you think about that
in terms of this uh
this uh racial element
that is very um what did you call it
it's incipient the in the
specifically in the white south
uh versus the urban
cosmopolitan north well when i think of
new york i think of pl
movies like um uh gangs of new york
or i think of uh like urban noir
new york noir where it's all about
prejudice
yes against like blacks and colonial
subjects but also
towards the irish and the italians
and it's it's a much more democratic
kind of racism there
it's evenly distributed no just because
they didn't consider italian
well the catholics weren't white people
like the catholics were catholics
it's about it's about like dirty uh law
men who are making deals with the gangs
and working with the mafia in order to
keep the sort of
baseline level of peace and sort of
identity
going on there without losing their
minds all right that's that's what
like american noir is about and
then you have the sort of uh well
american urban noir
and then you have the california noir
right which is more
like what adorno and horkheimer write
about in the culture industry which is
the fakeness of
hollywood and the sort of horizontality
of
of california versus the sort of
verticality
of the of the city on the east coast of
new york and that sort of thing right
what i was trying to get at though i
mean uh beaujolais book was written
in the in the 80s but what i was trying
to get at there was
the universal subject like the subject
that is universalized as a
white male for shorthand white straight
male for shorthand they don't need to do
identity politics because
they feel like the world is reflective
of their identity
would be the reason to signify yourself
but the south whites in the south are
excluded from that universal
identity because they're poor and
they're losers
so they have to create or fabricate
on identity politics in order to combat
that universal signifier which is you
know the coastal
educated like that's really interesting
that's actually reminds me so my friend
tucker who i was mentioning to you
before uh
before he he talked to me about how like
there's
a strange relationship to having the
southern drawl and the southern accent
where you feel
so i think some people will will take it
up and they'll almost turn it into like
an identity
thing potentially but then like uh
anyone who wants to be like an
intellectual and maybe join
that universal subject like it's very
important to get rid of that accent yeah
because right yeah it's easy to forget
that like stephen colbert for example is
from south carolina
and he basically had to like get rid of
that accent to be successful in media
yeah
and actually that's why a lot of
canadians end up getting hired to be
like journalists
like like anchors in the states because
like uh
canadians are seen as having like a
neutral
accent like generations was canadian
right midwestern accent
yeah yeah yeah you don't want anything
to place you right because you have
uh you have your sort of it's like in
england right you have all the local
accents and you have the sort of british
news anchor english
that's the same in the states right you
don't want anything to
identify you it's like when you watch
friends right they all sound normal
except
joey he's got the accent right but he's
an idiot so it's fine
well i think we're close to something
that could be called critical theory
here so
we're dealing with a universal and if
you don't fit that universal then
you attach signifiers to yourself um in
terms of identity
politics um i'm not saying identity
politics good or bad but the southern
reaction is definitely a reaction of
being
specifically excluded from that right no
that makes that makes a lot of sense to
me yeah kind of
and what eric just said is really good
that you don't want to be placed that
that placement the second that you can
be identified by the accent by your skin
color
by your sexual orientation whatever it
is the second that you are
placed then you almost have to justify
being you have to justify why you are
there and this could be
a way of explaining the mythology of the
south
is they need a justification for
existing having lost
and having been embarrassed if you want
to be taken seriously you could just be
a stupid womanizer hey how you doing huh
yeah but like i guess and i i think the
the
another way of like fitting it into a
lot of the polarized discourse we're
hearing today right uh
you know elitists right that word is
used all the time by
um middle america and and those who feel
and i think
you know what you're what we're
identifying as this universal subject is
i think they potentially like
that's the elitist right like the
elitist is the person who
fits into this like universal
free-floating subject
and uh of course middle america they
feel resentful of that of that of that
they
and that they're not part of that so
they're like well i'm just gonna assert
my
you know hokey set like like middle
america
or southern yeah exactly so it's like
that's kind of a way of reacting against
or that's i think that's what they mean
when they're talking about the elitist
right is like this and that yeah that's
what's so tricky about applying identity
politics as well to white identity in
particular right and that's why people
like richard spencer can kind of troll
you know black lives matter and say well
you know we can have our own kind of
like tribe then yeah
it's because like to this point like the
south was ethnically more cohesive in
terms of like their white
identity more than other places like new
york or california and
that's why there's still this sort of
like long-term
slow-burning crisis of like well what
does that mean to have like white
identity in relation to the universal
subject yeah right
is it intrinsically racist to affirm
your history like
this is still being negotiated yeah yes
it's very tricky but
in in the absence of like a more
mainstream solution that's where you get
like
again trolls like the alt-right
basically like coming up with extreme
stances in in this context
yeah there's something there's something
about embracing that
identity because when we're talking
about myth we can talk about mythic
signifiers and when people
use you know the their cultural myths in
order to
well what does anyone use myth for it's
to it's to control
their sort of life world their semiotic
space
so you have all of these oppositions
that you have to rise above your north
or your south your urban or your rural
your east coast
your west coast your black or your white
you have to as the universal subject you
have to try
to rise above all of those things and
you can go out larping
but that's expressing the mythic
signifier that's being in control
that's compartmentalizing that and
making it sort of cute and quaint and
part of your history but
you are above it really it's just saying
i'm here i'm here too
yeah it's it's i'm just thinking about
this uh
that term elite and it's kind of also
interesting to know how it doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with
like having money right like of course
it does often but
uh like i'm reminded of uh the if you
guys know the humorous friend leibowitz
she like used to hang around with andy
warhol she's sometimes on like
i forget i think she's on talk shows
she's been trying to like write a new
book for a while but failing
and uh she she had this comment about uh
she's been trying i don't know if you
guys have you guys heard of her like
fran liebowitz no she's like a new
new this new york like jewish uh like
really funny funny lady and
she she uh once said was quoted as
saying something about like in response
to this question about like elitism and
you know america you know do they really
hate the elites and she's like well some
people think about
like people with money and it's like no
americans love people with money right
right and she says no like what they
hate is smart people right it's like we
don't want any smart people
which is obviously like her
tongue-in-cheek way of saying like you
know and she was talking specifically
about like electability
right like an in vis-a-vis trump right
like he has money but he's not an elite
in a way for whatever reason but then
then you also have this anti-college
thing
exactly my stupid my stupid daughter
went to college and she came back and
now she's a communist or
you know that that sort of narrative
that you hear
or even now yeah the joke is that go
ahead
yeah i'm just gonna say like even now
with covid right like this this weird
polarization between following medical
advice and not and like you know
wearing a mask it's like oh that's
become politicized and if you like wear
a mask that means you're like an elitist
or like a liberal or something like that
because you're like following
what experts say this this kind of that
is an interesting thing to bring up to
like the
the way uh the the idea of the expert
and the elitist
and the elite and how those things are
tied up in this sort of like mythology
of of
of of distrust did you guys see the palm
beach commission on like uh
florida mandating masks and what the
reaction was from like
sort of locals did they bring their
bring their ghosts to the
civic building pretty much they were
they brought like their pitchforks
practically like they were saying like
this is the devil's work you're
banning god's breathing apparatus like
it's just yeah it's that's amazing
there's like actual footage
and this is like because after the
commission kind of like
had this law passed they had the chance
to kind of like hear from their
constituents and it was just
wildest stuff like it's it just shows
how bad this stuff has gotten where it's
like it's
it's sort of like un-american to like
put on a mask
in that context yeah and then in florida
right now as we're recording this i was
checking
it's i think today they had like 9 000
new cases just today like florida is
exploding was coveted
um i don't want to i really don't want
to end this because we got through all
that
labor almost to start doing actual
theory but we are uh
almost an hour and 20 minutes so do you
want to start doing
not short conclusions but long
conclusions trying to tie up
everything we've talked about in terms
of first of all the the
economic story or the the story of
capital
versus the story of the bourgeoisie
versus the story of protestants
um and how all of this stuff is
intertwined into this one
fabric textile of myth it's a tall order
i'm canadian and i want alaska back
what did you say something about quebec
i want alaska back oh you want alaska
back i don't we never had it
you gotta talk to russia about that yeah
russia was the one that had it before we
never had it
it must be important that was like the
bridge where like the humans originally
came
like 100 200 000 years ago
it's part of our heritage man was it
that long i thought it was like
11 000 years ago maybe
i don't know i'm going by homo sapien
time that's like three four hundred
thousand
years i don't know
there was an ice bridge it came to
alaska
okay so what have you guys uh thought
about here that you haven't maybe
thought about before and
try in trying to wrap up this uh
this myth into its many layers and then
almost
acknowledging the paucity of our own
canadian myth
in contrast to this rich this rich
fabric
that we have to the south which is good
you know bad and good
yeah i have something to say about that
especially like the canadian part i have
like sort of a theory about
uh which maybe this will fit into this
maybe maybe it won't but um
i think about the way like can like the
fact that in canada we don't really have
much of this
this rich as you were saying like we
have none of this sort of like rich
mythology at all and
i think i've often thought to myself
that one of the reasons why
we seem to have like functional
government even though we
nominally we have the crown still right
but i like i've often thought to myself
like the reason why
we don't have these like attachments the
way that america does to these
mythologies part of the reason anyway is
like
because we already have the crown uh
that like kind of like takes in so this
is like my i don't know what you guys
all think but like
that like almost takes away like this
like
to put we have nothing to put no okay
i'm i'm i'm like kind of mumbling here
but like
we have nothing to to place that sort of
like mythological
like affectivity into because we already
have the crown which
in some ways like absorbs all of that
mythological power
whereas in the states because they don't
have the crown they like have to invest
it they have to invest their like
mythological
like whatever so we're nature into we're
just into like the president we're just
[ __ ]
so then we have to put our whole
identity into just being nice
at least we're not at least we're not
mean because we never had to overthrow
the master right
so we just have the master and we accept
it so you don't need to have all this
ground swell
of mythological activity and artistic
activity to fill the void in your
in your soul we just look up there and
go okay
well we asked we asked nicely i think i
like kind of fumbled it there but like
well the point i was trying to get to is
like the fact that we have like a prime
minister right now who
doesn't like we don't we don't treat him
as anything special he's just like
this dude whereas like in the states
because they don't have a crown
they don't have a head of state yeah
they like invest all of their
mythological
they invest all of their mythological
power into the presidency so like
they're like respect the office of the
president like we don't believe in any
of that [ __ ]
because that's in it and then when a
muslim takes over the presidency of
course
then yeah you gotta like it because it
was here like do your gun training your
gun range training
yeah we have no mythological investment
in our prime minister at all like
there's nothing
he's just a minister he's just the prime
one but he's just another minister
whereas like in the states they
basically elect a king yeah
exactly so we have where's we just like
all over all of that mythology is in the
crown even though we don't care about
the crown
mm-hmm yeah
yeah i would say just like final
thoughts from me it's like don't
underestimate the importance of like
these narratives for certain groups and
give people an off ramp in terms of like
what they can believe in terms of their
identity right like if you want to
actually turn like a lot of these
protests and a lot of this sort of like
energy into like meaningful reforms
you gotta also understand where some of
these other regions are coming from and
like
why some of these myths have persisted
for so long and like
you you need almost like a sense of
truth and reconciliation like south
africa had after
apartheid and like we were talking about
like the south's never really had that
so unlike germany unlike south africa
like this stuff is still going to have
to play out for probably decades to come
but
ultimately it it's going to take a
better narrative to displace
the myths that have sustained people so
far you know it would be such
rich soil this would like if you're a
marxist
you should be organizing in the south
it's perfect
it's perfect soil as long as you can get
that whole cold war out of their heads
it's no the elites took this from you
and you can actually get it back by you
know seizing the means of production
god they've done such a good job though
the americans in in
like building this like immune system
against marxist ideas though
i mean like that they've done an inquiry
they did an incredible job of like
making that in that that would be a
monumental task i feel like it'd be
easier to
oh it would be way easier to convince
them uh like to be like fascists
they didn't hate they didn't hate bernie
though did they i thought there's like
they thought he was a good guy
they kind of man part of the reason he
lost the nomination is because he
wouldn't let go of the socialist label
though like that's
probably what like partly yeah yeah you
just call yourself
a communitarian or something the signal
the signifier of socialism
and like marxism is way too has way too
much baggage yeah
that's true anyway uh semiotics
what are you what is your
semi-semiatological
no that's wrong semiological analysis
of first of all what a myth do and what
do you need him for
and what have you learned in terms of
its utility in our neighbors to the
south
yeah i mean what i want to say is
i agree with the last comment these
narratives are powerful
and don't i'd add don't underestimate
the power of symbolism still with these
protests you know tearing down
statues and making statements like that
and subverting the dominant narratives
right yeah all that's what i want to say
but
also i mean that's all that's all like
long-term slow stuff and climate change
is going to [ __ ] kill us all before
any of that
really solves any problems anyway so i
got to stay true to myself and be like
whatever is happening now with kovid and
all this other [ __ ]
it's just a symptom of climate change
and golden one and we're all [ __ ]
so nothing if not consistent derek
that's my message you're looking at the
long game alaska
that's that's the next story yeah we
need to get it back
if i could also add one other thing like
kind of speaking to this is like i also
think it's pretty important like i think
we've been kind of
belittling the south a little bit here
uh uh
maybe maybe uh maybe a lot i don't know
but i think they deserve it though you
know
trying to understand it yeah yeah i
think i think it's also important though
to like
if we want to change people's minds to
like which is kind of speaking to what
litvik was saying like
we do have to be careful about the way
we do it because i think um
you know i uh it's in some ways i'd want
to have a principle of empathy like
having empathy for the fact that these
things are really important to people
and like that makes it difficult as much
as i might we might think it's
ridiculous especially from like a
canadian perspective
the mythology like you know i think it's
important to go in and have
some empathy for like the role that
these narratives and these
mythologies play in people's lives kind
of like the the stabilization or like
the ontological security it gives them
for like how they think about the world
and it's going to be hard to
change anybody's mind if we're just uh
stepping on and peeing all over it with
our with our
with our creative jokes yeah so to our
to our listeners in the south you know
if you're feeling bad about yourself for
all of this stuff just go out and buy a
hummer right what
what will make you feel better than
buying
a giant army vehicle that can burn loads
of gas
and gets like 10 gallons
that'll if you don't agree with us and
you feel bad about yourself
go grab a go grab a wife and get give
her a suv
and have a bunch of kids i would wager
to guess that not a single one of our
listeners owns a hummer
i hope not i mean it's hot i mean i like
your
let's be charitable thing i mean i don't
really like it i'll be honest well it's
not about being
able to having empathy i think that's
different about being practical i mean
the south
is just a morass of all these stupidest
it's first of all anti-intellectual
their christianity
is [ __ ] their christianity is mega
church garbage it's
so [ __ ] dumb it's like they have the
[ __ ] dumbest version of everything
everything's bigger than this well we
tried
so much so yeah we we tried yeah
so much so much for having just [ __ ]
chugging
two-liter bottles of coke that you get
with your
super-sized mcdonald's meal that is all
the south is to me so i i'm reacting to
obviously
that's the other thing yeah they have a
massive pr problem as well when it comes
to like anybody who hasn't been there
because if you just watch like larry the
cable guy or whatever the [ __ ] it's like
oh yeah fly over country but yeah
obviously
it's funny that the same that same
humorous i was mentioning before
friendly woods she said she's like if i
if i was like
the president and i could just solve
america's problem how would i solve it
she'd be like
lincoln made a big mistake like you
should have just let that go so let them
that's what they want
stop subsidizing their their idiocy
on every issue build some schools teach
them something different
no no they're state colonies schools but
they're two tax breaks to
zionist john hagee and joel osteen
whatever the hell you call that
[ __ ] death drive man hey i'll i'll
end on on one slightly diplomatic note
um
there was one sign i saw in mississippi
which kind of like brought some hope to
me was like uh
outside of um this uh kind of a bar
just like a black white man we're all
poor here
it was like just come on in and have a
have one on the house is that right next
to the abortion is murder
with an ultrasound picture with a smiley
face on it
billboard no those those guys were
across the street thankfully so
uh it was uh the chill side of town
all right well i hope we didn't have fun
at anyone's expense
i do enjoy southern barbecue though
obviously
good bourbon good barbecue music all
right
we should we should we should revisit
the topic of
uh narrative and identity um
probably with respect to a different a
different narrative that we might know
more about and
maybe feel less uh elitist
maybe maybe i i feel like i should have
invited my friend tucker the real
true blue southern americans please
don't let him listen to this i
i said some things i shouldn't have
although is is there such a thing as a
podcast which isn't elitist
it's it's it's tough to say yeah i don't
know no maybe covid will change all that
that it's our new national pastime
making fun of the way i was thinking i
was thinking before like i don't know
you know this maybe you
don't put this in the podcast but i was
like thinking about it i'm gonna put it
in ridiculous
off the record i was thinking about how
ridiculous it would be like could you
imagine like when we were talking about
like the revisionist history of the
south
like could you imagine if there's some
campaign in canada to like
rewrite the history of like the
residential schools and be like no that
was like about education
which i guess some people do say that
but there's not like a mythology about
that right like could you imagine a
mythology of like
of great educators we save their souls
we're also not we're just not as good at
telling stories either so like
in some ways it's worked in our favor
we're just not that interesting in terms
of national media i mean
victor is this pros and cons you're
right in bringing that up because that's
the analogy
like the worst thing that ever happened
in your country let's mythologize it
and say oh no they were just you know
fighting fighting for freedom
we were just trying to spread the spread
education it's progressive education we
tried our best we made a few mistakes
but ultimately we were just trying to
educate
spreading smallpox with education uh
yeah i mean
wasn't it wasn't it trudeau who just
apologized for that
once back or something yeah no foreign
yeah i don't know well the last one was
closed not too long ago
surprisingly recent eric you're our
resident trudeau whisperer do you know
when he said this
no i don't know i think it was part of
his uh electoral
platform i'm gonna legalize weed i'm
going to apologize to the indians
and i'm going to be real handsome
that was that was this you mean the
indigenous
of course i know i was just being a
curmudgeon
yeah all right you uh victor
literature victor thank you very much
we'll have you back
um for perhaps one of your other areas
of expertise
so from semiotics guy politics guy
and me plastic pills please don't
hate us for hating on the south you know
it's just it's low-hanging fruit
we shouldn't be punching down really we
should be focused this is mostly you
should be focusing on the horrendous
people that matter
uh jordan peterson michaela peterson
our worst exports if anyone's listening
to those podcast who's in the south like
i'm sure that they're probably uh
into critical theory and probably
wouldn't mean necessarily be that
offended by this yeah
they probably know better than us we
should do a call-in thing where
they can call we should do it they can
just um tell us you know
stop [ __ ] on us we've been [ __ ] on
by everybody else already
you're all sitting in your jeeps at your
gas station getting your
okay okay okay okay okay all right
bye bye bye bye
all right okay i guess we're i guess
we're signing off here cool
[Music]
you